Hi I'm Marc Bauer from the French Culinary Institute.
I'm gonna show you how to separate eggs.
That means I'm gonna separate the whites from the yolk.
First, I crack the egg on the side of a bowl or on a cutting board...
...and I separate with my thumbs into two shells.
Of course, I have a bowl below and the egg white falls into it.
Go back and forth until everything is separated.
In case you get a little egg shell, either in the white or the yolk,...
...you can separate it with a spoon...
...or you can let them sit for a while, especially in the egg whites...
...and the shell will fall to the bottom.
Just make sure you don't pour it into the final product.
That's how you separate eggs.